I think we can start from
[Music]
don't bring your body don't climb chill
in your corset knees stay over your hips
and your ankles not it allows us to
train on some things but it's not really
indicative of nanami architecture we
have multiple sections so the key
difference here is that in this factory
fall you're allowed to sit your butt
down my left foot is down and I am
allowed to break up I would wait
look at my head my head is going cold
that is contrary to the rationale of the
back break floor which is your head is
going backwards the dissenters going
forward got it
so we're letting do not do that and we
can do some training and the reason we
picked that one is this that these stops
you from breaking your down okay and
then everything else is fake so we want
to try to learn how to keep our Center
going forward this next drill I'm going
to try to do that so I will walk but I'm
not walking in your vertical leg anymore
I'm going to my office
which might start over and do the same
this is the next slide right it is a
little different I can see that maybe my
breath okay and what I want to do in
this drill is as much as possible stop
the butt from going backwards okay
because the next one we're not going to
so let's try this again
rather than me that when we do cami you
only go to this level don't pull back to
that other level okay and you always are
trying at least this note so on this one
I'm not going to walk back because when
I walk backwards my Center still going
that way
even though it's not pulling out so I'm
gonna just have my feet still and I'm
going to push my Center so far forward
and then a certain point I'm going to
contract it just like when I do any
projection so we were doing this
technique and when I go to throw
it looks like this if you come on this
plane I'm here like this I squeeze my
Center and it brings my extremities out
so I'm not going like this you see the
difference
I just flexed my cetera and you see what
happens when I release it boom bleep it
just drops okay so I'm gonna do that
question but the most extreme forward
progression of my hips that I can get so
it will help if I come off my heels
because that allows me to get going so I
keep going and I land on the same way
not enough I don't know I'm gonna keep
going
send them forward land the same way okay
the line of attack so I'm not jumping on
this line in my head stays on that line
I'm still going to have the same button
hook where my hips stay on the line so
my head is cleared the line the second
thing I'm gonna keeps I'm still going
down on the ball of my foot we'll find
the ball of your foot not with down
under instead you
okay so I have to find the ball of my
foot I take the side that's the ball is
what I go on I go on my wife on the
right hand is mine goes to the right so
I project keep going not enough on
enough
I want the bow to be taught the
bowstring boom you can see that I'm
finding that foot do the other side
they're gonna hold your belt and he's
gonna let go real fast do it you got it
absolute enemy so he's you know my
weight I'm gonna give it a I'm gonna
give him my Center so I'm Way back here
and when he lets go i flex you see I did
not so I don't like this new desk Allen
you see the difference
don't sit your butt down give up your
Center
he's got my weight you see he lets go i
flex alright partner up so when I was by
myself my Center was forward here's the
lawyer Mike
sorry see my centers one forward
standing O for don't go from here lean
back so the same thing when he asked my
center I'm not thinking like this I'm
giving up my Center see and he's got it
for up then he's holding it back that's
why some people can't hold okay so we
give up your Center he goes okay so when
I when I pick up my Center and I'm here
like this a Mets cap
watch how I float for a while you see I
don't even really go down right if I
have a flex my Center okay let's roll so
let's take our shirts we do it here and
you get it go into that position
there's going to get Tommy difference in
this evening on you it's going to be a
balance okay
my Nami Lawson is going to give him that
rhythm so that his Kimi Raja can fulfill
this drill okay so I go over all the way
all the way down
[Music]
and then the next level to Kennedy you
don't have a shot alright so watch the
time in which we're going to use but
this part it bounces he goes boom in
turn throw projector not here not there
no here get off your pills
and then be engaged then you'll contract
when I displace the clamshell dumb okay
alright let's go
and to me it's more realistic send those
final you like this is I get to actually
condition my mate so when he's here like
that there's a lot of mass on me and now
I have to move it and that's why so mu
leg engages pull-up that's your
projection on sequentially right last
one with you here why is it easier as
you can cheat each one and as we go on
and on I'm taking away the room for G to
get it so the last one the one before
this is easier because you have your
arms to do all kinds of weird thing hold
on in this person family and now that
all you have this blitz that's it and
that's why we're losing that's how
you're doing it so you have to try your
best so on table you're not here watch
out for me but accepts himself into the
position now see how long you can flew
but before you have to actually fall
when they messed up the rhythm right
you'll find their leg so here I have to
accelerate myself note just accept
accept accept see my weight I would come
look at my face
he's just here he's gonna do the rest
so he goes whoop and I just walk so I'm
not using any muscle in the aerobic
capacity I'm just accepting and he has
all my mask and have to move as I didn't
move it to get it so it's more of a
psychological barricade because we're
like I don't know how well you're not
from there you're not gonna find this
road they have to protect you
do you understand the other mckimie you
were throwing yourself
this is that's how you can this one he's
throwing me so I don't look toward the
throw when I'm in the middle I'm
perfectly fine in there okay fight you
fight on you she gets you there watch oh
I can just not use muscle or any aerobic
capacity did you see that
but I didn't say my can be either I'm
just accepting what's happening okay
that's where we want everyone began okay
all right let's go
okay so this half this side everything's
going this way he goes turning already
we don't then flat on our backs right
our head goes around the line of attack
so it doesn't remain on it so that our
lower body is not not pushing our head
to the target more into the ground
okay try it again remember that there's
a relationship between target was of
architecture and the Academy was
architecture they're like jigsaw puzzles
that have to go together
so our architectures are a little
different in this case other
architectures assume that if you are
doing what we call a back right fall
your Center is actually going forward
not backwards in space so we need to
develop a fall that we can do and this
going to disseminate that energy in
but also does it not make sense in an
art that is that was born in a culture
where the concepts at the end of young
was born that if I am using my Center
contraption to project again that at
some point in response week it must have
the center contraction as well so I does
not make sense that Doggett was up I
employ a center conductor contraption
have some sense of projection and then
bouquets just wet noodle it makes no
sense in the union culture okay so
you're actually doing what we always say
you're doing Luke it is just the mirrors
the other side of the mirror to nage
so you do you're not just stepping down
got it you're not just making yourself
safe you are training in the same
mechanisms that not yet is to do you
understand that so and then please
understand the way that us human beings
are he said there's a kind of
silent collusion that happens where we
through our fear want to throw ourselves
and we in our pride don't want to do
what is necessary to learn how to
actually throw people so they we come
and meet in the middle I will not do all
the sacrifice and commitment necessary
to learn how to throw you and you will
throw yourself and I'll meet you there
see how that happens and it feels like
it works but it doesn't work it is the
masquerade must be able to project you
yet even against you cos will and you
can must be able to receive my will even
when it is contrary to their world
and we struggle through this
and we meet instead and that other movie
that I just strung okay some training
tips
hey you just threw me just had your mass
thrown onto the map it's gonna tenderize
you you might describe that it's gonna
hurt
I call it tenderizing it's making you
supple okay
the more in shape you are the less
recovery time you need from that the
more flexible you are less recovery time
the better your sleep the better you
nutrition the less recovery time the
stronger you are the more muscle mass
you have the less recovery time it is
one of the reasons why we emphasize the
strength component because it allows you
to endure the learning curve of the
tenderizing process you don't have to
miss as many classes you'll heal like
but the next morning you're like let's
go I'm ready to go so again please think
of your training more broadly than just
class time do the things that prepare
you for the training and consider that
preparatory work the training all right
any questions
watching Andrey watching that G was a
video and the real thing that I
continued well one of the things that
I've continued struggle with is just how
exhausted I get for no apparent reason
and I wouldn't say that I was also
negative despite the slow tempo but
see the tension in my body
Sarah we need to be there and also just
there
it's another one of those
counterintuitive things where if I could
accept what's happening at a release
like you just share to this that great
fall well now no gate has to move so
much more wait I'm one of the biggest
guys here and they would not throw me
hardly anywhere and then I wouldn't have
to freak about do coming yeah and it
would go away though for anyone even
smaller so I'm far from one of the
largest people here but I still not
doing any work you you're throwing me
and I get up and now it's my turn right
so even though I may exhaust you and you
become more accepting in your kidney and
now I'm not exhausting you doesn't mean
you your noggin laws that should exhaust
me
should be this wonderful interplay of
energy manifesting a conflict and then
being neutralized by those parties and
that's all it is
conflict neutralization conflict new
choices we want to skill and
neutralizing conflicts and that's all
it's supposed to be happening in Keylong
laws up but if it sits I think the
ability to see when it doesn't happen is
more difficult and keep on it's much
more obvious than gee was that when
there's no conflict resolution what's
causing the floating to happen or not
happen really Adam I think you
well if you think about it because he
went down right and then the rhythm goes
boom lift to it you see and if I stayed
engaged I should be lifted but when my
Center disengages the butt is already
like like a balloon with a hazlit of the
air coming out the energy is going out
of your body so you can't be projected
right it's a search the part we didn't
get to is our base displacements you see
when we do our base displacements like I
kind of hinted at yesterday you will not
be able to step you will not find that
foot that foot will not be there for you
the closest you get to this crack break
fall is that inner hand that's it
do you understand you won't be able to
step back you won't be able to lower
your butt you won't be able to decide
when and how or where you're going to
fall because you don't have the path all
trading tools that you use right now
okay you're just going to be spun in
space and then you're going to drop so
all you have is the boom right the
contraction and the inside hand so if
you look at what we did as we went from
one move to the other one we were taking
away certain things that's what I was
calling cheating we were taking them
away we stopped we were allowing you to
move your Center backwards we were
allowing you to move your Center down
now we'll allow you to move your Center
backwards but not down you see that now
we want you to move your center forward
which means we won't let you move it
backwards and you can't move it down to
see that
more eventually we have to take away
that foot that step it will not be them
but you must land see when are you
releasing that flexion
well you never totally shut it off
remember remember in the beginning it's
got to be tight your Center is always
engaged but when you do a projection
it's going to contract you can
[Music]
you're not ever shutting it off just I
have a fist and I pumped it do you see
but I still have what this yeah I don't
go
the whole day everything that sinner is
still like I know yeah
no because you you know the reason why
the foot is gone and can be done is
because of nagas energy is so displacing
you won't have that energy when you do
it by yourself so there's I wouldn't
recommend that what I would recommend
for you and for you and to you is that
you really work on opening up open up
this throat in this chest and shoulder
area and
except that the Aztec e'en sacrifice
okay because you don't want to and
that's what's stopping so I would do the
drill where you have your Center going
forward you stay on the line and you
make your hips go forward you get off of
your heels you make sure your Center
doesn't drop and really just work on
psychologically opening that up because
fear is what's stopping you from doing
this you get it sometimes but it's very
dependent on which not it is it do I
think they hate me
did I miss the last one up and now
they're going to kill me or did I miss
the last one up and you know what I mean
it's it's too relevant relevant to what
the hell's going and that's not a
universal that's not centeredness okay
so practice this acceptance there there
is an acceptance in noggin noggin right
I accept where the elbow is I don't
force them to be someplace else
well there is an acceptance in who Kimmi
was that too
and what are the biggest in the way that
not yet rejects what Luke is doing
because they want to not be vulnerable
they feel threatened so they're going to
force it well the same thing would get
feels threatened so who gets going to
try to get so you want to use your Kimmi
just like your Nadia Wazza accept your
death accept your release and I think
you can do it more in Nadia Wazza
because we might who knows what's gonna
happen you know I mean you could land on
your head you could jack up your
clavicle you could break your shoulder
so it's a great place to practice it I
think it's a much more viable practice
in releasing and reconciling fear
reconcile